[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits et grands amis est-ce
que mais qu'est ce que tu fais grosse
chute patron chute je regarde si la
petite souris est passé ah oui c'est
vrai je me rappelle est ce que tu trouve
quelque chose je ne vois rien haha
voilà voilà pas trop où le joli regard d
une pièce en vrai argent
c'est magnifique j'ai bien l'impression
que p'tit louis va être très content je
pense bien europe
je vais lui portait bompas pauvres oui
oui mais dépêche toi au point pas trop
propre au port aux voiles alors la
petite souris mini ville d'hautmont
allons deviner dans quel patins passelac
celle là c'est maintenant du don c'était
un mois la danse de mado à moi je vais
vrai c'était là dedans at il oui et
c'est que la petite souris à apporter
c'est pour petit louis ouais moi je
crois que c'est dans celle à
[Musique]
o o calmerait 11 que les gentils cette
petite souris noire on dit si tu la
rencontre qu'il dira bien merci de ma
part elle est vrai - cette pierre way
[Musique]
tout tombe argent j'avais dans ma
tirelire
excellente idée au label tu relis tu
sais elle est presque plein on nous
attend voilà
jimmy la pièce mais c'est vrai il y a
beaucoup de sous là dedans tu retires
tirelire heures il a mis ses sabots
manger des abricots brill chat de janot
qui joue du pipeau
il s'est mis sur la tête il à faire
la pilote il a poussé la brouette il
accueillit des demoiselles tirait
thircuir jrce avenir tu retires tirlo
baudon
[Musique]
borg vite le cher petit garnement
là c'est un la lumière à demain un gamin
de nous
merci à la petite souris non aux bonnes
micky louis pomi mirabel
que
bonsoir petit louis bonsoir petite
mirabelle
bonsoir les petits enfants si vous êtes
bien sage
demain nous ferons ensemble un très joli
jeu et vous aussi vous jouerez avec nous
on opte patron il ne faut pas que
j'oublie de dire merci à la petite
souris
si nous la rencontrons dans le ciel nous
le lui dirons sans faute en route mon
vieux nounours bonne nuit les enfants à
demain à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh